you know you start out as a sole founder
that feels courageous enough that you've
kind of given up a day job you're
starting a business you think am i crazy
to be doing this
taking that first person on is like a
massive leap of faith
and of course it it gradually kind of
almost gets
easier because you face the fear and you
do it anyway and if you just keep on
facing the fear and doing it anyway you
know you'll look back in two years time
and think wow we're now a team of 15 how
did that happen
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
and is sponsored by leumitech hippo
insurance touring upwards labs and
hillel at stanford
managing a community is hard imagine
managing one of 75 000 people
meet emma jones the founder of
enterprise nation
following a degree in law and japanese
emma joined international accounting
firm arthur anderson
where she set up the inward investment
practice that attracted overseas
companies to locate in the uk
in 2000 by the.com bug emma left the
firm to start her first business
tech locate which was acquired after 15
months
her current company enterprise nation
has expanded to become a small business
membership community of over 75
000 people emma jones thank you for
joining my show how are you
i'm very good michael thank you for
having me on the show
it's wonderful having you here i'm
really excited to hear about your
journey
and you know today you're very much in
in the tech scene you're one of the most
the most you know popular and well known
and respected people in the united
kingdom texting but that
wasn't really the case when you just
started out starting getting a degree in
japanese
and and la right so tell me a little bit
about
how you get started with japanese and
you find yourself
running a 75 000 person community in the
tech ecosystem of the uk
well there were lots of years that came
in between but uh
so the japanese came from the fact that
i went to
an international college to do uh what
in the uk is called
a levels i don't know what you'd call
them in the states but it's kind of the
exam you take when you're 18 years old
um sap yes that's i was going to say
maybe it starts but i wouldn't want to
assume that that's what it was but i had
gone
to an international college um i lived
in a place in the uk called shropshire
it was in the middle of the country
and i went to this international college
where there were four british people and
everybody else was from all over the
world it was just this incredible
just kind of hodgepodge of international
cultures
languages vibrancy um so i went to study
there
and this was um in the years when i mean
the japanese economy is still
strong now but then it was at the time
when
lots of japanese companies were moving
into the united kingdom
you know japanese electronics companies
were doing incredibly well they were
becoming
world famous and i had applied to
university just to study straight law
and of course when you're sort of
growing up you're always told from your
parents you know become a lawyer an
accountant a doctor so i thought right
i'll take this kind of quite serious and
steady kind of degree um but then i met
all these incredible
international students and thought well
actually maybe it would be more
appealing from a business perspective if
i added
japanese onto it because i'll do law
which hopefully can help you in lots of
different kind of business occupations
but actually if you've got that language
surely that will kind of help me
go further do more things so as you say
i studied law and japanese that involved
spending a year in japan
when i was uh 21 which was incredible i
lived with a homestay
japanese family which was just a
cultural massive shock for a british
girl from the middle of the country
i'm sure um but taught me a huge amount
of things about business i started my
first business when i was there in japan
uh teaching japanese kids how to speak
english so
that was kind of my first
entrepreneurial experience and
as i say kind of japan really taught me
to to kind of grow up actually because i
could see
that the way that they had built this
incredible economy was essentially
lots of people working really hard and i
think i've gone out there as kind of
quite a playful
university student you know i was having
a good time
and and i think what that country taught
me is to
uh serious myself up and kind of put
some work ethic in and then hopefully
you'll get the return
so yeah quite an incredible experience
i love that and then you see you join an
accounting firm but i want to jump to
the
to the 2000.com bubble that burst and
and you you mentioned to me that you you
know you had that that bug
the 2000.com bug which led you to create
your first company which was also
acquired within i believe 15 months
so how does that how did that even
originate and how do you quickly pick up
all the things that you
that you need to know in order to run a
successful business that gets acquired
uh with lots and lots of help so um
that's probably the biggest learning i
had actually from that first business so
as you say i'd joined a big very big
accounting firm at the time called
arthur anderson straight out of
university
uh they sadly kind of went down when i
left them actually on an accounting
scandal with a company called enron
uh but at the time anderson's was an
incredible place to work and actually
for any of your young listeners who are
thinking i'm gonna start a business i'm
gonna leave college and
start out straight away i have to say
one bit
of advice that i offer and admittedly
this is based on my personal experience
but for me i could not have started my
first business
if i hadn't had that five years
experience with arthur anderson
so joining the firm they taught me
how to build proposals they taught me
how to deal with clients they taught me
how to pitch
you know i i literally would not be able
to sell if it had not been for that
experience of dealing with clients and
knowing how to present
a proposal and so it was an incredible
five years
it built a client network for me so i
had confidence i had contacts
and i don't think i would have had that
if i'd started a business
straight out of university so i did the
five years at anderson's
um it was the year 2000 it was the
height of the dot-com boom
and everyone was incredibly energized at
that time
and it was just this amazing moment to
start businesses
so i started a business called
teclacate.com
and what that company did is essentially
um what i was doing for arthur anderson
was what was called inward investment so
again this was helping companies from
all over the world
locate into the united kingdom and it
was a very messy process
and of course one of the incredible
things about dot-com companies
is through putting something online you
can hopefully make the process
more efficient and take the friction out
of it
so i essentially tried to build this
business
which as you say was a very short-lived
one to take the friction
out of the inward investment process so
my first company was with a co-founder
we launched uh we didn't raise any money
we just went out hustling to go and get
our
founding capital um and yes
within two years we'd got a call from a
quoted company
which was called tenon and essentially
they said we've been watching you
we really like the look of your business
do you want to sell
and back to this question of how on
earth do you know everything as to how
to start grow and then
exit a business within a two-year time
frame
fortunately we had a really good mentor
in that business so a guy who'd been
around the block he'd started
grown and sold businesses before and it
was just invaluable that essentially
anything that we didn't know i was 27 at
the time my co-founder was 28
we'd never run a business before so we
would just
run to our mentor and kind of say what
do we do now
and i will never forget just as again as
a final piece
of um kind of information from that
episode
is uh when we were approached by this
company who wanted to buy us
they had made the approach and
essentially they said to us what do you
want sell for what kind of price
are you looking at and so we ran to our
mentor and we were like okay we've been
approached by this company they've asked
us how much we want to sell for
how much do we want to sell for and i
will always remember him saying and i
just it's a piece of advice that's just
stayed with me forever
is he said look you know from an
accounting perspective of course we can
look at the value of your company it's
10 times your ebitda which in britain we
call earnings before interest tax
depreciation
so of course you can do that accounting
approach but he said the thing is
first of all they've made the approach
and the value of a company
is whatever someone is prepared to pay
for it
right value of a company whatever
someone is prepared to pay for it and
this is the thing we said of course it
is so
we went back to tenon we said to them
look you name your price and then we'll
let you know if that's something
that is amenable it was and so within a
couple of years as you say i'd
sold the business and then i did what's
called an 18-month
lock-in clause which means i then stayed
working for the acquirer and then
right the day on the day that was
allowed to come up i was off and started
the next one
amazing so speaking of the next one and
i think that it's a it's a perfect segue
talking about the mentorship you
received and the advice that you got
from from the experts from those that
have that have done it numerous times in
the past and
you know i think that there's a very big
shift in general especially in silicon
valley and where i'm from in tel aviv
where
you know institutional money is no
longer just a mechanism for you to be
able to extend your
to extend your runway but it's it's now
more than ever about that about forming
these partnerships with those that have
that have done it that have done it
before and have advised so you're saying
you know you know a multitude of of
investors wanting to invest in the same
company and the company now it's a
two-way street
getting that expert advice so i can
totally see what you're saying here
but even before we talk about how you
solve that need with enterprise nation
which i have to say i'm blown away by
the community that
you've built there talk to me a little
bit about the the tech ecosystem for
small businesses
as you see it so it's not really a small
startup it's not really a huge
enterprise
you really started understanding some of
the
the issues that small businesses are
facing right
well i guess i mean i'd love to say that
the tech ecosystem in the uk is very
strong
we have massive startup rates in the uk
and again if i kind of look back
back in 2012 i was involved with a
campaign called startup britain which
was a big
national effort to encourage lots of
people to start businesses
and kind of on the back of that and lots
of other things besides we have a really
positive
environment in the uk towards
entrepreneurship it's really
easy to start a company there is a lot
of external finance
there's huge amounts of support whether
you're you know starting a tech business
or a fashion business you'll find
someone
or some organizations that are there to
support you
and so i guess what the uk has always
tried to cultivate is
this environment where if you want to
start a business and just run it on your
own terms
i mean this used to be cool but i hate
this term like a lifestyle business so a
business where it just earns you an
income
but you're happy with that then the uk
has got a very conducive environment
but actually just before um coming on to
speak to you michael i tweeted
about a speaker who's going to speak for
us an event we've got on saturday so on
saturday we have an event called startup
we've got 2000 startups rocking up of
course it's online
it's the ninth year this event has
happened it's the first time
we've had to host it online because
normally everyone comes into a building
we do all this physically but anyway
and we've just announced a brilliant
british entrepreneur
who launched the business hopping which
uh whether you're
in tel aviv or silicon valley i think
you'll have heard of so
um the founder johnny um started this
business in 2019
uh he's well he started it in the uk
and hopkins has become a unicorn
business within the space of two years
so it's valued at two billion dollars
wow i have to say he is now running it
out of san francisco so there's a
there's a key question for the uk there
is how did we help launch someone and
then lose them
to silicon valley but at least we got
him started
um and so this is the kind of thing is
is hopefully kind of back to that
you know what is the scene in the uk
whether you want start a business and
use shopify as your
tech foundation to kind of build an
e-commerce shop or whether you want to
be a johnny and launcher hop-in which
is valued at 2 billion within 24 months
it's you are welcome to do that and it's
kind of the uk has cultivated this
incredible
can-do attitude and to be honest with
you michael everyone in this country is
just hoping that things like
brexit don't have a negative impact on
that so we're all
kind of holding our breath and hoping
that the entrepreneurial spirit in this
country remains
so when you say that the uk is
supportive of evidence i'm assuming that
you're referring to you know the
regulators the government that they're
taking active approaches to to help
entrepreneurs
run their small businesses or
potentially reach
reach those unicorn statuses right well
it's we actually think of kind of these
three constituent elements that i think
you have to get right
when you're kind of looking at building
a whole environment the government has
got a vital role to play so
absolutely when it comes to regulation
creating sandbox environments
that's really important so the
government has to do its work
the other element though is large
corporates so
we have this angle we're an incredible
headquarter location for the likes of
amazon
uber delivery facebook and of course big
corporates are always looking to
sort of buy in innovation into their own
company right
so that can create a really kind of
first of environment for
new startups is if you're a new startup
and you think
maybe i might get acquired by one of
these big companies or i can sell into
them so we've got a really strong
kind of corporate venturing sort of
activity and attitude in the uk
so this kind of government the role of
big corporates
and then the third thing is essentially
the role of your
fellow founders so do you have strong
peer networks
in a country where and michael you'll
know this is when you're starting and
growing a tech business or any business
it can be very lonely especially if
you're a sole founder
you have challenges every day you've got
constantly things to think about
and to be able to have a really strong
peer network
it is probably the thing that will make
the difference between whether you keep
growing that business or you decide to
give up
so i think all of those kind of if you
get those three things right government
big corporates plus cash as well
and then kind of strong peer networks
then you've got a good
kind of circular economy to hopefully
help tech founders do well
and i think that that also leads us to
the conversation about you know what
you've understood about this both
the peer networks i guess or the support
that that small businesses need so even
if they have the runway
even if they have the support of the
government they have the right
co-founders and they have the right
employees
it's still not enough to to go through
that journey
successfully so what was your insight
into that
into that scene and then how did you
build enterprise nation
to to tackle that problem well yeah i
was going to say enterprise nation was
built to help people to
get through that so yeah and as you say
we're kind of now and
you know it's an incredible business to
run because we are very community-led
um even though interestingly i have had
to become more of a tech
founder as i've grown enterprise nation
because we are a platform business where
a marketplace that connects small
businesses to all the support and advice
they need
and therefore if you looked around my
home office at the moment it is filled
with books
platform strategy the lean marketplace
platform revolution so
i am vociferously reading at the moment
on how to build a platform business so
you know we're always evolving
enterprise nation
in terms of it has to deliver on the
needs of the community
and our community increasingly wants
access to
support advice content resources and
therefore we just have to keep on
building
an ever more effective platform that
connects them to doing that so
enterprise nation absolutely was created
to help kind of small businesses
essentially get through that growth
phase the most difficult thing
literally the most difficult thing when
starting a growing business
is going for that first hire
it's kind of how do you go from you
right too
so you know you start out as a sole
founder that feels courageous enough
that you've kind of given up a day job
you're starting a business you think am
i crazy to be doing this
taking that first person on is like a
massive leap of faith
and of course it it gradually kind of
almost gets
easier because you face the fear and you
do it anyway and if you just keep on
facing the fear and doing it anyway you
know you'll look back in two years time
and think wow we're now a team of 15 how
did that happen
right we're bringing the sales in and so
our job at enterprise nation is to
give people both the confidence they
need to take those steps
but also to give them kind of the
practical information
to get it right right and so
obviously leading a community of you
know of 70
000 people is much different than
leading a community of you know
as if you're an accelerator and you have
a small batch of small businesses that
you're helping so what have you learned
about operating a community at scale
providing value at scale because
at the end the value is for every small
business asks itself okay what did i
gain from being a part of enterprise
nation so it has to be still very
personalized
while it's at scale how do you balance
those two seemingly clashing
you know ideologies and and you know
kpis
so it's a really good point and it's a
question we raise almost every day in
the business how do we offer
a universal service to a large number of
people and
um in the past 12 months we've had over
half a million small businesses come
onto the platform
looking for answers to their questions
looking for support so
how do we offer a universal service to a
lot of businesses
whilst giving absolutely you say that
deep experience where they felt they had
a personal connection with someone
and this is where it comes back to the
fact that what we are increasingly
is a marketplace so the only way at
scale
that you can support up to half a
million small businesses
with human actual advice that's relevant
to their needs
is not by enterprise nation delivering
that advice to the business
but is by connecting that business owner
with a multitude of advisors so on our
platform right
we've got over 15 000 advisors on our
platform so these are accountants
social media experts hr advisors
and you know i never want to have a
company where i've got
15 000 people on my payroll who i'm
paying
to advise small businesses but all of
these 15 000 people
they run their own business they are in
the business of giving advice to small
businesses
our job is to very quickly identify the
need of the small business owner
so a business owner comes on to
enterprise nation we have to really
quickly find out
where do you need help is it sales is it
is it finance
as soon as we know that we have to make
what we call make the match
how do we make the best match between
that business owner
and the kind of support that they need
in the form of people
content and events so that's the way to
do it at scale
is by connecting one person to a whole
group of support they need
but hopefully whilst doing that in what
feels like
a friendly environment where you feel
you know the people who are delivering
it so
it's the constant challenge of how we
get that right but
hopefully i love that doing okay
i know it sounds fascinating and i think
that the way you're thinking about it as
a marketplace and the value of providing
both so the person is giving the advice
and
person getting it i think it's
remarkable and it's definitely
how it should be so emma thank you so
much for joining my show it was really a
pleasure having you here
20 minutes go by way too fast but the
most important question that i have to
ask
is three words that you would use to
describe yourself
so i hope you don't think this is a
cop-out michael but the three words i'm
gonna use
are love's small business
i love that emma this was wonderful
thank you
very very much best of luck i can't wait
you know when i have a small business to
join the enterprise nation as well and
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
same to you michael thanks for having me
take care